ABSOLUTELY, ALWAYS THERE FOR
YOU, SEAN, CONGRATULATIONS.
>> Sean: REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
>> Laura: AS WE MENTIONED AT
THE TOP, WE ARE VERY HAPPY NOW
TO HAVE VICE PRESIDENT
MIKE PENCE WITH US AND YOU HAVE
TO FOLLOW HANNITY,
MR. VICE PRESIDENT, THAT’S JUST
THE WAY IT WORKS.
>> Vice President Pence: GOOD
TO BE WITH YOU, LAURA.
>> Laura: IT’S GOOD TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT, I UNDERSTAND IT’S LATE,
YOU HAD A LONG DAY.
YOU SEE THIS NARRATIVE TAKING
HOLD, CASES RISING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, SCHOOLS ARE WAFFLING ON
OPENING, GOVERNORS ARE PULLING
BACK ON SOME OF THEIR REOPENING
ESPECIALLY IN BLUE STATES AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE GIVING
THE ADMINISTRATION MIXED MARKS
ON THE HANDLING OF THE VIRUS
EVEN THOUGH THE HANDLING OF THE
VIRUS HAS BEEN SO MUCH BETTER IN
SO MANY WAYS IN RED STATE
AMERICA THAN IT HAS BEEN IN BLUE
STATE AMERICA SO WHAT ARE YOU UP
TO DO TO CONVINCE VOTERS
ESPECIALLY IN MIDDLE AMERICA
THAT YOU’RE DOING THIS RIGHT,
MR. VICE PRESIDENT?
>> Vice President Pence: WELL,
LOOK, I THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE SEEN THIS PRESIDENT
TAKE DECISIVE ACTION FROM VERY
EARLY IN THE CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC.
LAURA, BEFORE THERE WAS A SINGLE
CASE OF COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION,
BEFORE THE END OF JANUARY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP SUSPENDED ALL
TRAVEL FROM CHINA, STOOD UP TO
THE WHITE HOUSE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE AND IN THE FIRST FEW
WEEKS OF FEBRUARY, WE ACTUALLY
BEGAN THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING
A VACCINE AND YOU JUST HEARD A
WEEK AGO THAT WE ARE ALREADY AT
A HISTORIC PACE IN PHASE THREE
CLINICAL TRIALS OF THE FIRST
CORONAVIRUS VACCINE FOR THIS
COUNTRY, COULD WELL BE AVAILABLE
FOR THIS FALL.
IN THE MIDST OF ALL OF THAT,
WE’VE TAKEN TESTING FROM A
STANDING START TO NEARLY
60 MILLION CORONAVIRUS TESTS
PERFORMED.
PPE IS IN GREAT ABUNDANCE EVEN
ACROSS THE AREAS OF THE COUNTRY
WHERE WE’VE SEEN RISING CASES.
AND WORKING CLOSELY WITH
GOVERNORS AS THE PRESIDENT,, AND
I HAVE FROM THE VERY BEGINNING,
NOT ONLY DID WE CONFRONT THE
DRAMATIC RISE IN CASES, THE
CRISIS THAT EMERGED IN NEW YORK
AND NEW JERSEY, CONNECTICUT,
DETROIT, NEW ORLEANS.
THE GOOD NEWS AS THE PRESIDENT
SAID TODAY AS WE ARE ALREADY
BEGINNING TO SEE ACROSS THE
SUN BELT, NOT ONLY THE
STABILIZATION OF CASES BUT CASES
ARE CLIMBING, DECLINING,
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS ARE
DECLINING, AT THE END OF THE DAY
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THAT TH
PRESIDENT HAS SPARED NO EXPENSE,
RESPONSE BUT THE WHOLE OF
AMERICA RESPONSE AND IT’S ALL
JUST EVIDENCE OF THE KIND OF
LEADERSHIP THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS BROUGHT TO THIS COUNTRY OVER
THE LAST THREE AND A HALF YEARS
AND I AM READY TO TAKE THE STORY
OF THIS PANDEMIC BUT ALSO THE
STORY OF THE WAY THIS ECONOMY IS
ALREADY RECOVERING ON THE
FOUNDATION PRESIDENT TRUMP
POURED IN THE FIRST THREE YEARS,
WE’VE ALREADY PUT 7 MILLION
AMERICANS BACK TO WORK IN THE
FIRST FEW MONTHS OF THE RECOVERY
RECOVERY.
>> Laura: I WANT TO GET TO
THAT IN A SECOND BUT STATES LIKE
FLORIDA AND TEXAS ARE STILL
DOING MUCH BETTER ON COVID THAN
NEW YORK, THAT’S JUST TO LOOK AT
THE NUMBERS PER MILLION, A
FACTOR OF FIVE OR SIX BUT
EARLIER TODAY GOVERNOR CUOMO HAD
THE GALL TO SAY THIS ABOUT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION’S HANDLING
OF THE VIRUS.
>> WE DO NEED TO RESET FOR THE
RESET HAS TO START AT THE TOP,
WE HAVE CONFUSION, WE HAVE
CHAOS, WE DON’T HAVE OPERATIONS
SET UP AND I THINK IT HAS TO
START WITH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, I THINK HE HAS TO
STAND UP AND SAY WHAT HE DIDN’T
SAY SIX MONTHS AGO, HE HAS TO
SAY TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT
COVID IS SERIOUS.
THE WHITE HOUSE, DR. BIRX, THE
SECRETARY, THEY ARE SENDING THE
EXACT WRONG MESSAGE.
THEY’VE LEARNED NOTHING IN SIX
MONTHS.
>> Laura: YOU’VE LEARNED
NOTHING IN SIX MONTHS?
YOUR RESPONSE TO GOVERNOR CUOMO?
>> Vice President Pence: OUR
HEARTS GRIEVE FOR THE FACT THAT
ONE IN FIVE OF ALL THE AMERICAN
LIVES THAT HAVE BEEN LOST IN THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC WERE LOST
IN THE STATE OF NEW YORK AND
SOME OF THAT WAS BECAUSE OF POOR
DECISIONS BY THE STATE AND BY
GOVERNOR CUOMO BUT LOOK, I LIKED
IT BETTER WHEN HE SAID THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S LEADERSHIP IN
THE PANDEMIC WAS, IN HIS WORDS,
"PHENOMENAL."
HE SAID THAT REPEATEDLY AS WE
SEARCH TESTING, SAILED IN A
HOSPITAL SHIP, BUILD HOSPITALS
IN NEW YORK.
I COULDN’T BE MORE PROUD OF THE
SUPPORT THAT WE RENDERED TO THE
PEOPLE OF NEW YORK AND I THINK
THE PEOPLE OF NEW YORK KNOW
THAT, HEALTH CARE WORKERS KNOW
THAT, FAMILIES KNOW THAT, I KNOW
GOVERNOR PHIL MURPHY JUST ACROSS
THE RIVER HAS CONTINUED TO
EXPRESS HIS GREAT APPRECIATION
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
LEADERSHIP.
BUT THERE WILL BE PLENTY OF TIME
IN THE FUTURE TO DEBATE VARIOUS
RESPONSES.
LOOK, OUR FOCUS IS ENTIRELY ON
DEALING WITH THIS PANDEMIC,
MARSHALING THE FULL RESOURCES OF
THE GOVERNMENT AND I THINK THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW THE FACTS
HERE AND THE FACT THAT
GOVERNOR CUOMO HAS BEEN ON AGAIN
OFF AGAIN, COMPLEMENTED THE
ADMINISTRATION’S RESPONSE AND
THEN HE PIVOTS TO CRITICISM, I
THINK PEOPLE SEE THROUGH THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO STAY FOCUSED ON
THE TASK AT HAND AND PROTECTING
THE VULNERABLE IN PUTTING THIS
CORONAVIRUS IN THE PAST.
>> Laura: MAIL IN BALLOTS ARE
A LOOMING DISASTER, WE ARE
SEEING THIS IN NEW YORK AND I
FORESEE A SCENARIO WHERE
PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD ACTUALLY
BE AHEAD IN KEY STATES ON
ELECTION NIGHT BUT THOSE STATES
COULDN’T HAVE COUNTED ALL THE
MAIL IN BALLOTS.
PHILADELPHIA, DETROIT,
MILWAUKEE, MIAMI-DADE, YOU CAN
FORESEE A SITUATION WHERE THIS
WILL GO ON FOR WEEKS, WHAT CAN
YOU SAY TONIGHT TO ASSURE US
THAT THIS ELECTION WILL NOT BE
STOLEN BY DEMOCRAT ELECTION
OFFICIALS AND SWING STATES?
>> Vice President Pence: LOOK,
THE PRESIDENT MADE IT VERY
CLEAR, WHETHER IT’S THE POWER
GRAB IN NEVADA, THE GOVERNOR OF
NEVADA WAS SIGNING THAT ALLOWED
NOT ONLY FOR UNIVERSAL MAIL-IN
BALLOTS BUT ALSO VOTE
HARVESTING, AS IT’S CALLED, WE
ARE HEADED TO THE COURTS.
THE RIGHT TO VOTE, THE ONE
PERSON, ONE VOTE TO WRITE IS AT
THE VERY CENTER OF OUR DEMOCRACY
AND THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT WE ARE NOT GOING
TO STAND IDLY BY WHILE YOU SEE
DEMOCRAT STATES AND DEMOCRAT
GOVERNORS USE THE BACKDROP OF
THE CORONAVIRUS TO SEND MILLIONS
OF BALLOTS ALL ACROSS THEIR
STATES AND ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY.
LET’S BE CLEAR THOUGH, LAURA,
ABSENTEE BALLOTING IS PERFECTLY
ACCEPTABLE.
YOU HAVE TO APPLY FOR AN
ABSENTEE BALLOT, SIGNATURES ARE
CHECKED, IT’S CONFIRMED, IT HAS
A LONG TRADITION AND WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE ANY AMERICAN THAT IS
NOT ABLE TO GO TO THE POLLING
PLACE FOR ANY REASON TO APPLY
FOR AN ABSENTEE BALLOT TODAY BUT
THIS UNIVERSAL MAIL-IN LOADED
VOTING WHERE YOU’RE GOING TO SEE
LITERALLY BALLOTS SHOWERED ALL
ACROSS THE STATE IS RIPE FOR
FRAUD AND WE ARE HEADED STRAIGHT
TO THE COURTS TO PUT A STOP TO
IT.
>> Laura: MR. VICE PRESIDENT,
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
JOINING US TONIGHT.